monthey est chargé un fusil d'assaut
en quelques heures ces civils ukrainien
apprennent le maniement des armes de
guerre en cas d' attaques de l'armée
russe une formation express dispensés
par des soldats de la garde nationale
ukrainienne
pourquoi suis je venu avec mon fils on
se prépare à toutes les éventualités et
je veux qu'il soit prêt
je suis prête à nous défendre si quelque
chose arrive je défendrai ma maison ma
ville mes enfants je le ferai et je
serai prête au moment venu
la tension est encore montée d'un cran
dans la région
les états unis ne cessent d'alerter sur
une invasion russe jugée imminente
au cours des dix derniers jours nous
avons vu une accélération dramatique de
l'avancée des troupes russes qui
pourraient à tout moment lancé une
offensive militaire
pourrait être cette semaine
mais bien sûr l'ordre d'attaquer n'a pas
été formellement donné et donc on ne
peut pas dire à quel moment précis cela
pourrait commencer
mais le dialogue n'est pas rompu les
échanges téléphoniques se sont
multipliés entre dirigeants occidentaux
et russes en témoignent ces appels entre
emmanuel macron est vladimir poutine ou
encore entre le président ukrainien et
joe biden olaf scholz est attendu
aujourd'hui à kiev avant de rencontrer
vladimir poutine mardi pour tenter une
nouvelle fois d'éviter un conflit armé
les discussions diplomatiques se
poursuivent mais jusque-là elles n'ont
pas vraiment permis d'apaiser les
tensions